I read the sports section first I i I'm
a bit cynical in the wayward and I do
not speak for people i work with when i
say this is strictly me I sometimes feel
like rooting for any political causes in
a way like rooting for a football team
you have about as much effect on it and
whoever wind has about as much effect on
the what actually happens in the world
at least in this country that's strictly
me speaking for me and maybe I don't
always feel that way I the things that
bother me about save the world today and
politics today and and I I can't maybe I
would have felt exactly the same 50
years ago I mean everybody thinks their
age is the worst and but I hate being
lied to and I hate I feel like there are
so many cheap lies being thrown at us I
think we are being I hate being treated
like an idiot and you know our
government treats us like an idiot it
treats us like a child and i'm not
saying oh this is this administration
either I I will never forgive Bill
Clinton for lying to me he treat took me
for a chump he said I didn't sleep it
just say do you you're going to say
it but he really okay he said it he said
it that sincerely all right I believe
you oh you know screw you he really he
lied to all of us and it's like it's not
a big deal yeah it's a big deal he
really he took us all for chumps he
thought of like in light of these people
and you know you don't just do that one
to do it in every occasion you can I
hate being lied to I hate being and I i
think i think thats related to the
problem of the government treating us
like we're children and which you know i
think they think we're stupid and i
think they think were children and I
think we act like we're children you
know because we let them do that
no it's a give-and-take sort of thing
but you know the more they treat us like
children the more we act like it and the
more they take away from us you know I'm
an absolute you know freedom of this
freedom of that guy I'm very pro gun you
know I'm pro school choice i'm crazy you
know I but I just I I think we need to
be treated like adults i think we
Americans you know we have these
hard-won liberties and we really just
sort of have to cling to them every
chance we can get because you know they
never get rid of laws every law they
write basically get stuck on the books
forever and they all infringe on our
rights in some ways I mean I think in
some ways we have to sort of our duty to
fight every law they get to put on the
books yeah it's it's hard not to feel a
little trapped by if people lined was it
becomes it's also like you don't feel
like necessarily they're doing it in
your self-interest there you know it's
okay your mother drives you crazy when
she you know tells you to tuck your
shirt in but you know she's doing it
because she loves you when our
government tells me to tuck my shirt and
I don't know why they're doing it you
know I think that it's doing it to be
bossy so um that's how I feel our
biggest challenge we have so many
challenges I did it's all the people
it's so many people with so many things
they care so passionately about and it
um I think we have a lot I think people
expect us to make a transition from a
very sort of patchwork quilt world where
you know people in Asia and people in
North America and people in Europe
ahadees very distinct cultures and
beliefs and religions and and now
because of how media the world is and
we're all in contact with each other or
somehow supposed to make
use very different machines function
together you know these very different
pieces of Clockwork go together they're
not going to fit and and also you know
it's not just the different cultures
it's the cultures of you know the Bible
that I revere the sort of this ancient
religion and then a modern world where
you know there are we somehow expect to
be able to fit very old cranky ideas
into new modern sleep packaging into
into progressive egalitarian Walton
they're not going to fit you know and I
think you know one of the things like we
will show you with a religion you have
to go okay well that's crappy but that's
part of it you know but you know i don't
know why i can t bacon you know that's
it you know and ended there there I
think much more ludicrous things with
any religion too but I think the biggest
problem is um is we're somehow expecting
the progressives among us you know
expect us to make this sort of great
leap into a space age where you know
everyone is tolerant and this and that
isn't that we've got so much I would
call it baggage of our previous cultures
with us but I would call a baggage
except I think a lot of it's really good
that's not going to get on that
spaceship with us you know that's going
to keep the spaceship grounded III don't
know how we're gonna make it all fit the
war seems like an obvious choice in this
country and actually in the world I
don't see how there can be any other
real issue until it's resolved you know
until we've won or until the war's over
that's our only issue there are how best
to win how best to you know
and not just for us but for the world
you know but what do we have to do
that's because people are dying every
day because of this I think there are
second to that it's a education and in a
way for some more reason because and
it's not going that's not going to be
the second most important thing but but
everyday people are kind of dying
because of our school system too that's
one thing that aggravates me is
everybody always talks about in
complains about the problems with our
school system and you know we do this in
that but but nothing ever changes and
nothing changes in interest or right now
kids are in crappy schools and nothing's
going to you know that's not going to
change and that's that's quite like as
crazy as it is I see me I feel like well
let's just do school voucher because
let's let's do something let's do
something for like a mother who wants to
send her kid to a good Catholic school
you know let's just let her do it right
now and until something better comes
along just get it's just so frustrating
me to think of that all the kids in the
shitty schools right now yeah but the
war that's got to be it hopefully the
hopefully they will be over by 2008 you
know and we'll be able to concentrate or
another thing